you
right
We welcome everyone. We welcome
you. It is Thursday, April
9th, 2026 and we will convene
this meeting of the Huntsville
City Council. We are met in the
chambers in Huntsville,
Alabama and all council members
are present. We welcome everyone
who has joined us this evening
or who has joined us online and
we are grateful for your
presence. We will begin with an
introduction by Dr. Sonny Hatcher,
one of our Huntsville, Alabama
public safety chaplains. We are
grateful for their service and
our Pledge of Allegiance
tonight will be led by Scout
Noh Hitchcock of Troop 361 and
we welcome all the Scouts of
Troop 361. We will begin with
Dr. Hatcher followed by Scout
Hitchcock. All who wish to stand
for the prayer and the pledge,
please do so.
Let us bow our heads. Heavenly
Father, we simply pause to say
thank you first, God, for your
grace and your mercy, God, that
has covered us and followed us
throughout this day. We pause in
this moment to acknowledge you
as the source and the wisdom of
all guidance and all truth.
Lord, as decisions are made in
this place tonight, let them not
be driven by division but
represented in love, anchored
in unity, and carried out with
honor and respect for every
citizen represented here
tonight. Give these great
leaders clarity where there is
uncertainty, courage where
there's pressure, integrity that
does not bend. Father, we lift
up our first responders and our
military, those who run towards
danger while others run away.
Cover them, God, protect them
and strengthen them. Let them
return home safely to their
families. And let your peace
rest over this city, binding us
together, leading us forward
and reminding us that we are
stronger when we stand united.
We trust you, we honor you, and
we invite your presence into
this moment tonight. In your
name we pray, amen.
Amen.
If you will, please join me in
the Pledge of Allegiance
I pledge allegiance to the flag
of the United States of America
and to the Republic for which it
stands, one nation, under God,
indivisible, with liberty and
justice for all. Thank you.
Thank you, Dr. Hatcher. Thank
you, Scout Hitchcock. We
appreciate you opening our
meeting in such a wonderful way.
Councilmember Hitchcock, I
appreciate you opening our
meeting in such a wonderful way.
Councilmember Hitchcock, I
appreciate you opening our
meeting in such a wonderful way.
Councilmembers, we will move
on to the approval of the
agenda. Please note that item
16A has been deleted at the
request of the sponsor. Are
there any other changes to be
made to the agenda? 16A. Any
other changes to be made to the
agenda? Is there a motion to
approve the agenda? Move to
approve. Chair, the motion from
Mr. Little, seconded by Ms.
By Mr. Kling. All in favor,
please indicate. Any opposed?
Motion carries. The agenda is
approved. Councilmembers, you
have the minutes of the regular
meeting of the City Council
held on March 26, 2026 before
you. Are there any changes or
additions to be made to these
minutes? Seeing none, the
minutes will be accepted. We
will now move on to the Mayor
who has a couple of special
recognitions. Instead of taking
the moment, we are waiting for
everyone to arrive for that.
We will move on to 5B. 5B is a
proclamation to declare April
9, 2026 as Women in Sports Day
to commemorate the
achievements of the Alabama
A&M and UAH women's basketball
teams. Mayor Bell. Ms. Watkins,
if you would come forward with
me, I don't think you missed a
game this year. But we would
love to have from the
UAH and the Alabama A&M, we
have the presidents of both
universities here. We have a
number of people from the
sports departments here and we
have players here. We would
love to have them come up front
so we can have a proclamation
about great achievements that
they have made and the things
they have done for our
state. Thank you.
Thank you, Governor.
Applause
A&M this side.
We'll let the president stay
kind of in the middle. How are
you?
I'm great. How are you?
Good. Good.
Guys, thank you.
We have side and side because
we have to get pictures. That's
the most important thing. We
have to have pictures to
commemorate this day. This
says whereas the city of
Hustle proudly recognizes the
vital role that women's
athletics has played in
strengthening our community,
we have achieved historic
groundbreaking success during
the 2025-26 season bringing
distinction and pride to the
community. Whereas the Alabama
A&M university lady bulldogs
secured a historic southwestern
athletic conference, the SWAC,
regular season championship,
the first in the program
history highlighted by a
hard fought 55-50 victory over
grandmas and grandpas.
We have been able to win
55-50 victory over Grambling
State to cinch the title.
Congratulations.
Whereas the University of
Alabama and Hustle Chargers
women's basketball team
completed the most successful
season in program history
advancing to the NCAA division
two final four for the first
time and achieving a program
that will be the first in the
program history.
Whereas the Hustle Chargers
also captured the first golf
south conference regular season
championship. Whereas these
student athletes exemplify
dedication both on and off the
court serving as role models
and ambassadors for their
universities and for the city
of Hustle. Whereas it is
fitting for the city of Hustle
recognizes and celebrates
the first of its kind.
We are hereby proclaim
April 9, 2026 as women in
sports day in the city of
Hustle. Thank you and
congratulations.
Applause.
For you, Dr. Williams.
One for you, Dr. Carr.
Who is going to speak for the
university?
Before we move on, I want
everyone to know that we have a
celebrity in the house tonight
and a lot of people don't
understand it. When you go on
social media, you see coach
Dawn Thornton, her outfits are
followed throughout the sports
world. And I want to thank
her for that. She has really
made a statement and an impact
at Alabama A&M University.
We are going to get her to say
a few words.
Applause.
Good evening. First
congratulations to you ladies
and coach at UAH. You all set
the tone for our season.
Thank you. They beat us early
this season.
Just here to thank everyone
for taking the time out to
celebrate with us. This is a
wonderful day. Dr. Williams,
Dr. Bryant, thank you all so
much for all that you do for our
women in sports. We wouldn't be
able to do this without the
support of you all as well as
our administration at Alabama
A&M. It's a great time to be a
bulldog and we will continue to
strive to make the city of
Huntsville proud. Thank you all
so much.
Applause.
All right. We want to thank both
the mayor and the council and
everybody here for recognizing
these outstanding women. We are
absolutely honored to stand on
the stage with these young
people from Alabama A&M
University. They are certainly
a pride of our community and a
great tribute. We are really
proud of the young ladies up
here. We are proud of them
because of their basketball
record. We are more proud of
them because we believe that
20% of our grads at UAH and
many of the grads at Alabama
A&M will stay here and live in
our community. I'm very
confident that they will make
you just as proud as they have
us. Thanks for being here. Go
Chargers.
Applause.
Excuse me, players, before you
go, A&M family, will you come up
so we can take a picture,
please?
A&M family, come up so we can
take a picture.
One thing we forgot to mention,
Kayla Walker is the swag player
of the year.
And the HBCU national player of
the year.
Applause.
Congratulations, ladies, you
make us all proud.
Applause.
Five A is a proclamation to
declare the month of April as
the military child month.
Are representatives from the
arsenal here yet?
We will move on then to council
special recognitions.
Thank you.
Item 6A is resolution honoring
Amaya Wells for her outstanding
athletic achievements and
dedication to excellence.
Is there a motion to approve
that resolution?
Motion from Mr. Kling.
Second from Mr. Meredith.
All in favor, please indicate.
Any opposed?
Motion carries.
We will present that.
Will you come up, Amaya, and
we will let Ms. Watkins make
that presentation.
Thank you.
So while we're waiting on the
mother to come up, Amaya has
done some extraordinary things
this year.
She has been outstanding in the
track field, so we want to
bring you down today and
recognize you.
Whereas the city council mayor
of Huntsville, Alabama,
recognized Amaya Wells, a 12th
grade student athlete at May
12th, 2020, as the first
class 6A champion in the
class 6A.
She has been a champion in the
class 6A, both on and off the
field.
Whereas Amaya Wells has
demonstrated exceptional
athletic ability by earning the
title of 2025 outdoor state
champion in the class 6A 100
meter hurdles showcasing her
dedication, discipline, and
competitive spirit.
Whereas she continued her
career in the class 6A 100
meter hurdles, further
establishing herself as one of
the premier athletes in the
state.
Whereas Amaya Wells achieved
national recognition with a
fifth place finish in the 60
meter hurdles at the 2026
Adidas indoor nationals in
Virginia Beach, Virginia,
earning All-American status.
Y'all should be clapping by
now.
Whereas she is currently ranked
as the number one athlete in
the state of Alabama across all
classifications in both the 300
meter hurdles and 100 meter
hurdles and holds the number one
ranking in the 100 meter dash
for class 6A.
Whereas her accomplishments
reflect not only her individual
talent and perseverance, but
also her pride and recognition
that she brings to May C.
Jemison High School and the
Huntsville community.
Therefore, let it be resolved
that she will be recognized by
the community of Huntsville,
Alabama, hereby recognize and
honor Amaya Wells for her
exceptional achievements in
track and field, her dedication
to excellence in her
representation of Huntsville at
the highest level of
competition and commend her as
a role model for young
athletes throughout the
community.
Would you like to say something
Amaya?
I'm shy, but let me tell you,
the things that she has
accomplished definitely deserves
recognition.
I'm so proud to bring her to the
council and recognize her.
And we expect to see great
things from her.
So watch the Olympics, remember
Amaya Wells.
Thank you.
I don't see Colonel Ikey yet.
So we are going to move on to
seven announcements and
presentations.
7A is a presentation from
the Huntsville Salutes,
America's 250th committee, and
we will hear from Sally Warden
and she will introduce her
team.
Sally, come and tell us all
about our plans to celebrate
America's 250th semi-quincentennial.
Oh, you're the first one to say
it.
Good.
I'm glad you said it first.
Now we'll spell it, Jenny.
Okay?
We have a lot to celebrate
tonight and Jenny has given me
ten minutes to tell you
everything and we're going to be
pushing it to make it in ten
minutes, but I'm going to talk
super fast.
So first of all, thank you for
allowing us to come up here and
tell you everything that's going
on.
Couldn't do it without a great
welcome from the committee and
the mayor appointed a committee
last summer.
Many of them are here now.
I'm going to run through them
real quick because I'm asking
them to come to a meeting
tomorrow afternoon here as well
so I need to give them some
creds for being here tonight.
First of all, William Hampton
from Huntsville Revisited.
They're all mostly right back
here behind me in my chairing
section.
Kent Ballard from Parks and
Rec, Claire Aiello from the
Chamber of Commerce, David
DeLisser from Parks and Rec,
Erin Owen from the
Communications Department, the
City of Huntsville, Katie
Stamps, our Preservation
Planner, and Natasha Parker who
is a member of the DRA and she
is also the chair of the
committee that's actually
producing what's going on the
4th of July in downtown
Huntsville.
So you're going to hear from
her about those details in just
a minute.
I'm covering everything else.
Other, just so you know though,
this is a very diverse, broad
committee.
They are here on the committee
because they're either
producing events and programming
for 250th or they are giving us
great advice as we move forward.
We also have members from the
Huntsville City Schools,
Historic Huntsville Foundation,
Huntsville Madison County Public
Library, Alabama A&M.
I wish they hadn't left yet
because we have several members
from Alabama A&M on our
committee.
UAH has several members.
Oakwood has several members.
The Northeast Alabama Cherokee
Tribe, also from the Sons of the
American Revolution, the
Daughters of the American
Revolution, and the State Black
Archives.
So we have a lot of folks on our
committee and we've added a few.
We have some from Redstone
Arsenal as well that are
attending as well now.
But I really first also want to
tell you when the mayor asked me
to take this volunteer job, I
said I got to have some backup
from the city.
And they have come through.
Your City Parks and Recreation
Department, your City
Communications Department, your
City Music Office, and Katie
Stamps have all provided a lot
of help so far.
And we're going to be calling on
a few more departments as we move
forward, especially for that
parade.
So I also have to give a big
thanks to Downtown Huntsville
Inc.
They are an instrumental partner
for us since the event on the
4th is taking place down here.
They are going to be
instrumental in all of the
planning that goes on for that
day.
Finally, and not lastly, but
finally, I do have to thank
Metta and our dear friend,
Henry Thornton, who is no
stranger to this, well maybe to
this room he hasn't been in
there that many times, maybe
across the way you were there
more.
But Metta stepped up last fall
because we needed some money to
produce all of this.
And he, we gave him a pitch and
said, well, we can onesie-tosie
this for the parade and the
this and the that and the this
or you can be the exclusive
sponsor of Huntsville Salutes
America's 250th.
And he gave us a big blessing
by saying yes, they would do
that.
So I'm going to give Henry a
minute to step up and say what
it means to him to be the
sponsor of all these
monumentous activities.
Thank you, Sally.
Friends, new and old, esteemed
council members, Madam
President.
Good to see you.
Mr. Mayor and Tre.
It's so good to see all of you
and to be back among friends
tonight.
Our entire 300-person team up
at the Metta Huntsville Data
Center is so, so excited about
this event.
We love big gatherings where
people come together.
We love being an American
company and we love supporting
the Huntsville community in
lots and lots of ways that I'll
spare you from me doing all my
talking points.
I hear my brief sponsor
mentions today.
But I do want to do the prime
responsibility of any main
sponsor, which is to ask for a
round of applause for Sally and
the team doing all the actual
work.
We appreciate them so much.
Metta is so proud to be in
Huntsville.
We appreciate everything you
all do for the city and we're
very, very excited for July
4th.
Thank you all so much.
Thanks, Henry.
And thank you for being such a
great and easy to work with
sponsor as well.
Before I launch into everything
that's happening in Huntsville,
I want to give you guys just a
quick update to let you know
things are going on at the
federal level and also at the
state level.
And we work closely with the
state.
Arthur Orr, our senator, one of
the senators for part of
Madison County, is actually the
chair of that.
And because of our efforts here
in Huntsville to celebrate the
250th birthday, the state has
designated Huntsville as the
official Alabama semi-quincentennial
city, complete with a
proclamation and letter that
I've already given to your
council president and a flag.
So, ladies, they're going to
show you the flag that we have
received to be the official
semi-quincentennial city, which
that's the last time I'm
probably going to say that word.
It's kind of a fancy word for
250th.
Matter of fact, I'm going to
show you the flag that we have
received for the official
semi-quincentennial city.
And I'm going to show you the
flag that we have received for
the official semi-quincentennial
city.
Matter of fact, I was joking.
Turn around so everybody can
see it.
There you go.
There we go.
So we will display that proudly
in our activities out in the
round town for you all.
Another thing that is going on
at the state level are, I'm
going to say the word, those
semi-quincentennial schools
programs.
And I have a list here of the
Huntsville City schools that
have already signed up for that.
Just so you know, these are
schools that have signed on
board that say they're going to
have it in their curriculum, do
great things, do a community
service project.
And we're still working on
getting even more of them signed
up for that.
Also, the state has a great
website.
I know it when I hate it when
people stand up and say go to
the website.
But it is a very good website.
It has 500 pages of lesson plans
and things for the state that
the state has created, the
State Department of Ed has
created for every teacher in
the state of Alabama.
And actually, we've gotten
national grants for that.
And we've got a lot of
information.
And actually, we've gotten
national recognition because
when all the state of Alabama
folks went to the big meeting
up in Washington with all 50
states there, we were one of the
few states back last summer
that already had an amazing
amount of information out for
our schools.
As a matter of fact, 20 states
have asked to copy ours.
And we've sent the whole state
toolkit to them.
So it's amazing what the city
or what the state has done to
support our schools.
Now, I can't wait to tell you
about what's happening here
locally.
First of all, we have a website.
And it is a super easy website.
And it is America250Huntsville.org.
And we happen to have Aaron
Owen who created this website
for us.
It's simple, straightforward,
and it's where you can send any
of your constituents to go find
out about what's going on.
It also has places that they
can sign up to do things as
well.
That's the first opening page of
the website, actually.
I can't wait to get into this
list now.
And I'm going to start talking
fast, okay?
So this is the community
calendar.
The website is home to the
community calendar.
And these are just slides, guys,
that Aaron made up for us so
you can just get a sampling of
that.
You can also see all about the
July 4th celebration.
It's home to the community
calendar.
It gives the details of the
July 4th, and it also gives a
list of all of the committee
members as well.
Our community and organizations
in town and venues have really
gotten into the 250th in a huge
way, even ones that aren't on
the calendar.
Lots of them are doing projects,
especially the Sons of the
American Revolution, Daughters
of the American Revolution, are
doing projects that aren't
necessarily an event, but they
are ongoing things that they are
doing all throughout the year.
And we have a lot of them in the
community that are doing all
throughout the year.
Here I go.
Bird on the Mountain.
From March through September,
they are doing We the People
programming, providing hands-on
experiences for all those that
are attending up there of what
early American life was like.
They're also going to host a
very fun British Invasion Dinner
up there in May with Fife and
Drum Music, Pub Fair, and bands.
Over at Early Work, Constitution
Hall Park has already started a
series of free monthly programs
with panel discussions
highlighting topics of interest
of early American history.
In February, during Black
History Month, they had a panel
on Black Patriots Marches
Program.
During Women's History Month was
Women Revolutionaries.
Coming down the line are Lines
Drawn, the role of land
surveying in early history.
They have battlefield
communications, and they also
have newcomers forming a new
nation.
Those are all free, and on
Saturday mornings, the third
Saturday morning over at
Constitution Hall Park.
As always, Historic Huntsville
Foundation finds ways to make
history fun and accessible, and
celebrating 250th is no
exception.
Their signature celebration for
America's 250th will include a
May Preservation Awards event,
then the return of the American
Signature Quilt, known as the
quilt that saved Harrison
Brothers Hardware Store, a
presentation on quilts, as well
as a signature art show with the
theme, What Does America Mean to
You?, featuring the works of
local and regional artists.
The Huntsville Madison County
Library is hosting a free
luncheon speakers series
throughout all of 2026 about
the history, any history in
Huntsville of the past 250
years.
They actually started with one
last month on the indigenous
tribes that were here.
Now they're moving to the
Revolutionary Patriots that
here, who knew that so many
Revolutionary Patriots ended up
living in Madison County.
We had more living here than
anywhere else, actually, in
Alabama.
And as you would expect, the
library is celebrating books,
and each month in 2026, their
program, We the Readers, will
feature a book that they feel
could be the great American
novel.
They had Grapes of Wrath.
They have some I haven't even
heard of before, but they are
all books that will be
celebrated each month.
It is thrilling for me to also
share with you that Theatre
Huntsville is presenting the
Tony Award winning musical
1776, which brings history
alive with songs and a
behind-the-scenes look at the
passion and sometimes chaos
that led to the signing of the
Declaration of Independence.
Theatre Huntsville is going to
have 11 performances at the VBC
Playhouse, 11 in the month of
June.
So they have one every weekend
basically in the month of June
at the Playhouse.
One more from the arts
community is an American Mosaic
which is From Hymns to
Hollywood, 250 Years of America
Sound.
It's a free concert that's going
to be held actually after the
4th of July in July, I believe
it was July 15th, at First
United Methodist Church
featuring the powerful and
expressive voice of the organ.
Free concert.
We have two events though that
are going to start off the
weekend countdown to the
Huntsville Salutes, America's
250th Celebrations in
Downtown Huntsville.
Both of them are free.
So what we're hoping is that
people will see everything we
have going on in Huntsville and
decide instead of going to see
their family and wherever their
family wants them to go, they
need to have their family come
here because there are so many
free events, especially leading
up the week of the 4th of July.
Down it did a landing exactly a
week before July 4th.
They'll be putting on a special
250th edition of their annual
Independence Day celebration
with food trucks, live music,
fireworks, more details to come
on that later.
And one time only event on July
the 2nd, just two days before
July 4th, Rocket City
Celebrates America's 250th is a
free concert featuring the 151st
Alabama National Guard Band at
Joe Davis Stadium.
This is put on by several groups
but the lead of this patriotic
concert is Hunts Spring D.A.R.
Chapter.
Now, oops, I was supposed to
click the calendar of events
while I was reading through all
that, guys, sorry.
There they are.
But if you go to the website,
America 250 Huntsville, you will
see all of those and you can
click and get, that's just a
quick little glance.
It goes into much more detail
and tells what time everything
is.
And we are adding more every
day.
Erin is actually taking care of
adding those and every day we
have more and more events coming
in.
Now, this, guys, is very
exciting.
One of the most exciting and
most visible things in Huntsville
will be 40 banners that will
soon be hung on some of the
major thoroughfares throughout
Huntsville honoring
contributions made by the brave
patriots who established our
nation.
Right now most of them are
empty.
Matter of fact, all of them are
empty, I think.
And so these will be going up
and this is brought to us, the
D.A.R. chapters.
We have five D.A.R. chapters in
Huntsville.
This is a great story and a
great story of cooperation and
collaboration in honoring
something, the patriots of the
250th.
But it's the coordinated efforts
of them.
Penny Sumner, who you all
probably know, she's not able to
be here tonight, but I've got to
brag on her and say her name.
She, you know, was a retired
principal and she had her best
retired principal hat on when
she decided to take this project
on.
She did it in an amazing amount
of time.
All five D.A.R. chapters applied
for the same grant.
The state was giving out grants
to groups like D.A.R. and S.A.R.
to produce events.
Well, all five of them got on
board to do it.
All five of them got the grant
and then they turned around and
have ordered these banners
together.
So it's a great story of
collaboration and we're going
to hopefully keep them up the
whole rest of 2026, I would say.
But one of the masterminds behind
this, who is also a D.A.R.
member, is Natasha Parker.
And Natasha was the one that came
to me even before the mayor and
John Hamilton came to me and
said this and said, what are we
doing for the 250th?
And I said, well, funny you
should ask that.
I think we're going to be doing
a lot of stuff.
And she had the vision for the
day and she is going to come up
and she had the vision actually
for these banners.
And then she also had the vision
for what it would look like in
downtown Huntsville on July the
4th.
Once in a lifetime opportunity
to do something like this,
once in a lifetime opportunity
and as I told the mayor, it's on
a Saturday.
You know, we have to have a big
party in downtown Huntsville.
So Natasha's going to come up
and give you the details and
more details are coming every
day.
Every day Parks and Rec is
deeply involved in that day and
have been a great partner with
the committee on that.
So Natasha?
Thank you, Sally.
And thank you, council, for
having us here tonight.
So for Saturday, July 4th, we're
having a big day of festivities
to celebrate the semi-quincentennial.
We're actually currently looking
for some volunteers from our
citizens to help with a variety
of activities.
So on our website that Sally
mentioned earlier, which again
is America250Huntsville.org, you
can go to the top of the page
there and click July 4th
celebration.
There's some information there
about the day, but we are still
looking for some vendors for Big
Spring Park.
So for any citizens that may be
interested in participating as
a vendor, there's a vendor
interest form there.
We're still looking for some
parade participants and there
is a parade participant interest
form there as well.
And then finally we're still
looking for some volunteers for
the day for a variety of events.
So there's a volunteer interest
form on the website as well.
So if anyone in the city is
interested in volunteering,
becoming a vendor or
participating in the parade, we
encourage them to go to the
website and fill out one of the
forms there under the July 4th
celebration tab.
As far as the activities for the
day are concerned, there will
be a parade that will start at
5 p.m.
It will go through downtown
Huntsville and end at Big
Spring Park.
The theme of our parade is
American Eras.
We'll be highlighting various
time periods throughout
American history from the
American Revolution all the way
to the technology age.
So it's a moving storyline
of our American history for the
past 250 years.
And we would like to take this
opportunity to formally invite
each of you council members to
participate in the parade if
you are interested.
You can be looking for an email
from Mr. Kent Ballard about
that.
For the rest of the activities
we're going to have some
programming in Big Spring Park
that will begin at
approximately 4 p.m.
We plan to have a DJ setting up
kind of a festive atmosphere.
We'll have some food trucks set
up on Williams Street.
The vendor booths will also be
in Big Spring Park along with
we're working to have some
reenactments and
demonstrations as well.
We'll have some live music that
will start at 6 p.m. with one of
our local favorites, Groove,
and then Jazz McKenzie will be
headlining at 7 p.m.
We'll end the night with a
fireworks show with the Huntsville
Concert Band who will be playing
some of our American classics
from John Philip Sousa.
So, oh, I should have clicked
again.
Look, there we go.
Sorry.
So we're looking forward to a
really fun and festive day.
We hope everybody will come out
to Big Spring Park and celebrate
with us.
And we want to thank you again,
Mayor Battle and council for
allowing us to have this and
especially to Henry and Metta
for sponsoring the day.
Thank you.
Thank you, Natasha.
Thank you, Sally.
Council members, do you have
questions?
Anybody have questions?
Erin, I'm sure you'll be getting
this information in our council
member newsletters.
That would be a great way to get
the information out.
Thank you all for the work that
you are doing.
We look forward to it.
Council members, I have noticed
that Colonel Ikey is with us now
so without if there's no
objection, we're going to go
back to item 5A, proclamation to
declare the month of April as
the military child month and we
will let the mayor present that
at this time.
Thank you, Madam President.
If we could have everybody with
the military child education
come forward, Colonel Ikey, it
was Shane Davis' fault that you
were stuck in traffic today.
We'll try to do better next time.
We want to say thank you to each
of you for being here.
We have our superintendent of
education, Clarence Sutton, with
us.
Thank you for being here.
Excuse me.
Would you like to introduce your
crew here?
I'm Debbie Madry with military
child education coalition.
Jennifer Holliday, I'm the
military family liaison for the
state of Alabama.
Melissa Lindsay, executive
director of student services for
Huntsville city schools.
Dr. Clarence Sutton from
Huntsville city schools
superintendent.
He's a very shy person.
Yes.
Colonel Ikey, thank you for being
here for this.
As we do this proclamation, we
do this proclamation every year
but that doesn't lessen the
importance of it.
Every year it means something to
us.
It says whereas the city of
Huntsville is proud to be the
home to a strong, vibrant
military community and whereas
military children play a vital
role in supporting the mission
of families by demonstrating
resilience, adaptability,
and courage as they navigate the
unique challenges of military
life.
Whereas these young individuals
serve alongside their parents in
a very meaningful way, often
facing uncertainty with the
strength and perseverance
beyond the limits of their
ability to do so.
Whereas the city of Huntsville
is proud to be the home to a
strong, vibrant military
community and whereas the
military children play a
vital role in supporting the
strength and perseverance
beyond their years.
Whereas the month of the
military child provides an
opportunity to recognize and
honor the sacrifice,
contributions, and unwavering
spirit of the military
connected youth.
Whereas Huntsville is committed
to supporting military families
through partnerships with the
local schools, organizations,
and community leaders to
ensure that military children
are recognized, supported, and
celebrated.
Now therefore I, Tommy Battle,
mayor of the city of Huntsville
hereby proclaim April 2026 as
month of the military child.
Thank you so much for all the
child that you've been.
On behalf of the military
community, Mayor, I just want
to say thank you so much for
recognizing the military
families and their children.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
You know, it's amazing when you
get down to the facts of this.
You know, many of the military
families move six, seven, eight
times and just in their
you know, K through 12 years.
And so everywhere they're going
they're having to make new
friends.
And you know, I think it's a
very, it's essential for us as
a community to make new friends
every day and to make friends
with those who are new to our
community, who are coming into
our community and make sure
that we make this the best place
that they can ever be.
So y'all are doing that on a
day-to-day basis and I say
thank you for the job that
y'all do.
I'll give you that.
Thank you.
And Shane Davies will work on
the traffic problem so you
won't get stuck in traffic next
time.
Thank you.
Thank you all so much.
Well, we've had a lot of a lot of good news stories to get us started today.
A lot of good things going on in Huntsville, a lot of good people doing good work.
So now let's recognize more of that by getting the business of the city done.
We will move on now.
We have no matters with outside legal representative, so we move on to public hearings to be held.
9A is a public hearing to consider and act upon all objections or protests, if any, for
removal of a public nuisance.
At 195 Wilkinson Drive, Northeast Huntsville, Alabama, in consideration of a resolution
ordering abatement of a nuisance located at the same property.
The public hearing is now open.
Mr. Irwin.
Yes, Mayor Battle, Council Member Scott Irwin, Community Development Department.
This public hearing is in reference to the property located at 195 Wilkinson Drive, Northeast.
The property was in violation of the State Public Nuisance Act regarding junk.
Community Development issued a notice to the property owner and interested parties.
The property remains in violation.
Community Development is seeking your authorization to abate this junk public nuisance.
The condition of the property is before you on the video screen.
Property owners, as identified by the Massacay Tax Assessment records, were notified of the
time and place in which the objections may be heard involving the abatement of this public
nuisance.
Thank you, Mr. Irwin.
Is there anyone here who wishes to comment in this public hearing?
Is there anyone who wishes to comment on this matter?
Seeing none, the public hearing is closed.
Is there a motion to approve the resolution?
Second.
Motion from Mr. Kling, second from Ms. Watkins.
Any discussion?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
Thank you.
9B is a public hearing authorizing Community Development to assess the cost of cutting
overgrown grass and weeds against certain properties and consideration of a resolution
pertaining to the same.
The public hearing is now open.
Yes, Councilmembers, this is a public hearing on a resolution authorizing Community Development
to charge for the grass and weed removal on designated properties.
The attached resolution authorizes assessments for the 40 properties listed.
Of the 40 properties, 24 of the owners reside within the sea limits of Huntsville.
One property owner is outside the sea limits but within the State of Alabama, and 15 property
owners are out of the State of Alabama.
The total amount of the 40 property assessment is $12,655.49, with an average per property
amount of $316.39.
All procedural requirements related to the declaration, removal, and billing for grass
cutting and cleanup have been fulfilled in accordance with the City of Huntsville Code
of Ordinances.
Property owners were notified that an assessment may be authorized and placed on their property
at the City Council meeting scheduled for tonight, April 9, 2026, during which they
will have the opportunity to appear and present any objections to the assessed cost.
Thank you, Mr. Irwin.
Is there anyone here who wishes to comment on this item?
Anyone wishing to comment?
Seeing none, the public hearing is closed.
Is there a motion to approve the resolution?
Motion to approve.
Second.
Motion from Mr. Mayor to second from Ms. Watkins.
Any questions or discussion?
Seeing none, we will now move to the vote.
All in favor, please indicate aye.
Any opposed?
Motion carries.
We move to 9C.
9C is the public hearing authorizing the demolition of an unsafe building constituting a public
nuisance located at 13032 Chaney Thompson Road, Southeast Huntsville, Alabama, in consideration
of a resolution pertaining to this same.
The public hearing is now open.
Mr. Irwin.
Yes.
This resolution will authorize the demolition of an unsafe building constituting a public
nuisance located at 13032 Chaney Thompson Road.
The owner and industry parties were notified of this request and may be here tonight to
present any objection to the action.
We have photographs of the property for you to review on the screen.
This property was initially inspected by an independent contractor who determined that
the structure was not structurally feasible to repair.
Of a 100point scale, it was a 96 percent loss.
After an official notice was sent by certified and firstclass mail requesting the demolition
and removal of the structure by the 26th day of March of 2026, no action was taken by the
owners or industry parties and we are now requesting authorization to abate this nuisance.
Thank you, Mr. Irwin.
Is there anyone here who wishes to comment on this item?
Anyone wishing to comment, Mr. Cox?
Jerry Cox, 4029 Tailstar Circle.
Thank you, Madam Chairman.
Madam Chairman, my community for at least 10 years and probably closer to 20 years has
been trying to get a property that is only 10 percent better than what this property
is.
And every day we still have that property there of being a public nuisance to us, being
a hazard, an address to us, but we still can't get the action on it that the community at
this particular location has been able to get from the City of Huntsville.
We beg you to get this property torn down and out of our community.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Mr. Cox.
Is there anyone else wishing to comment?
The public hearing is now closed.
Is there a motion to approve?
Motion to approve.
Motion from Mr. Mayor, second from Ms. Watkins.
Any discussion?
Madam President, trying to stay on the subject, let me just echo Mr. Cox's sentiments.
I've seen it personally and certainly would hope we can do something definitive about
that property.
Any neighborhood that has to have a property that has deteriorated to this level or even
just 10 percent less than this certainly needs to have it addressed.
So will you have that conversation with Mr. Irwin here?
You all can step out in the lobby and have that conversation later.
Any other comments?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
All in favor, please indicate.
Thank you, Councilmembers.
Thank you, Mr. Irwin.
90 is a public hearing authorizing the Finance Director to issue a limousine license to Kirk
Parker to admit this as Starship Limousine Service for the operation of two limousines
and consideration of resolution pertaining to the same.
The public hearing is now open.
Good evening, Councilmembers.
Keisha Bryant, Director of Parking and Public Transit.
This public hearing is before the Council on the application of Kirk Parker doing business
as Starship Limousine Service for a business license so that he can operate two limousines.
One of his vehicles is a Cadillac ESV and the other is a Lincoln Town Car.
Mr. Parker has completed his application and also passed his background check, thereby
meeting the prerequisites to proceed.
Any questions?
Thank you, Ms. Bryant.
Is there anyone here who wishes to comment?
Anyone wishing to comment?
Public hearing is now closed.
Is there a motion to approve the resolution?
Motion from Mr. Merida.
Second.
Second from Ms. Watkins.
Do you have any questions for Ms. Bryant?
Hearing none, all in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed?
Motion carries.
Thank you.
Thank you so much, Ms. Bryant.
We have one public hearing to be set.
10A is a resolution to set a public hearing on the rezoning of 97.24 acres of land lying
on the east of Greenbrier Parkway and south of Huntsville Browns Ferry Road from Highway
Business C4 District to RezDust 2 District and introduction of an ordinance pertaining
to the same.
Is there a motion to set the hearing for May 28, 2026 regular council?
So moved.
Second.
Motion from Mr. Merida.
Second from Ms. Watkins.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed?
Motion carries.
That brings us to agenda related public comments.
This portion of the meeting is reserved for persons wishing to address the council on
matters relating to the specific content of items on the meeting agenda.
We have one person who has signed up.
When called, please approach the microphone, state your name, address and home of residents
and city residents for the record and you may address the council for three minutes.
Speakers shall refrain from entering into a dialogue with council members or city staff
and from making comments regarding the good name and character of any individual.
Ms. Joy Johnson has signed up and is joining us this evening.
Ms. Johnson.
Yeah, Joy Johnson.
I live on West Arbor Drive in Huntsville, Alabama, 35811 District 1.
I don't understand everything about the different commissions and everything, but I see two
items here in 16 about appointing people to the educational building authority and then
it says Madison Academy.
I was under the impression that Madison Academy was a private school.
I don't, I'm just saying I don't, I wish somebody maybe could explain to me what the
city item has to do with that.
Hang on.
Item 20N about getting into a cooperative agreement between the city of Huntsville and
the drug and DEA.
Just a little bit concerned that we might be over policing in particular some portions
of town over others and I certainly hope that that is not the case and do we even really
need to do this.
I would love to hear about 20R and the solar thing that's going on and 21A is a demonstration
of how easy it is if it looks like to me to change the name of a street.
I'll be danged.
You'll do this but not change the name of a street that is insulting to Native American
women in particular.
I don't understand what the problem is with that.
It looks like you can do it for a much less important reason.
Thank you.
We'll now go on and hear comments from Mayor Battle.
Mayor Battle, the time is yours.
Thank you Madam President.
Lots happening in the area right now.
Soccer has come back to the Rocket City and soccer will be taking place this weekend at
Joe Davis Stadium.
This is Community Development Block Grant Week and just the other day we were out at
a property that was being restored house by house in part of our city.
I want to say congratulations and thank yous to our Community Development Department because
they go in and take houses that may not meet the certain codes and they get volunteer groups
to help fix up those houses.
Most of the times those houses are owned by people who may be seniors and maybe don't
have the income to be able to fix up a house or to maintain and maintenance a house and
we're able to help them do that so that they can stay in their home longer.
We're able to rebuild a community and rebuild a neighborhood.
And I want to say thank you to Community Development for what they do.
Thank you to all the volunteers who work with Community Development.
There are churches that work with them.
There are civic groups that work with them.
Habitat for Humanity was there working with them.
Volunteers from across the city are helping their neighbors rebuild communities and rebuild
neighborhoods and I think it's one of those things we ought to be very proud of.
We also had 22 veterans here this week who were leaving the world of the military and
coming into second careers and we were telling about opportunities sitting right here in
Huntsville and I think we might get a few takers out of it.
And Artemis II splashdown watch party is happening in Big Spring Park East Friday night.
I think it's about 7 o'clock is the time that we're scheduled for a splashdown.
Should be a big party and we as a city need to come out and congratulate NASA, Marshall
Space Flight Center and all the groups there and all the companies that have been working
with NASA to make this happen for a great, great achievement by our country and a great,
great achievement as we go into future space exploration.
Baseball parks are opening.
We've already opened Mayfair Park.
Mr. Kling was there for us for opening Mayfair Park and American League and Liberty League
are opening Saturday at 9 and at 10 o'clock.
So one of the best days in the world is the day you get to throw out the baseball, open
baseball and say play ball and then you have five and six year olds who take over the whole
field.
The symphony is happening Saturday night and over the next two weeks I will be attending
the National Space Symposium out in Colorado Springs and also the Washington legislative
fly in.
For the record I would like to appoint Brenda Martin to the Huntsville Madison County Convention
and Visitors Board of Directors for a four year term to expire 41330.
I can't believe four years it will be 2030.
But that's all I have.
Thank you Madam President.
Thank you Mayor Battle.
We'll move to Council Member Comments and we will begin by hearing from Council Member
John Meredith.
Thank you Madam President.
I had the pleasure of going to the Dragon Alley ribbon cutting over in the mid city
and I'm telling you if you have a thing for Asian food you definitely want to go to Dragon
Alley.
They call it Asian street food but to me it's high end dining.
I mean it was wonderful.
They were kind enough for those of us that went to the ribbon cutting to give us little
samples and everyone at the table I was at loved everything that they served.
I mean no one said I like everything but that.
No everybody loved everything.
So I encourage you guys to get out there.
It's a must stop if you find yourself in that mid city itself or just near mid city.
It's worth going and stopping and eating there.
Also the pleasure of being invited to the UAH neighborhood nursing program.
They have several different stops.
The one I got to go to was in Triana.
Triana sounds like it's a long way away.
It is from downtown but it's literally if you count houses it's a fifth house from my
house is Triana.
So it's not that far away from the city of Huntsville.
So if you live in that general area down Zert Road down Walteranna Highway off Swan Cot
in that general area and you do not have a primary position I encourage you to start
going to the Triana location.
They're there I believe every week.
I forget the day of the week might be Thursday but every day of the week they're there and
you don't have to be a resident of Triana.
You can come from anywhere and they will take care of you.
It's a one stop shopping for all basic health care screening.
They have immediate references there on site if you have mental issues that you need dealt
with thanks to the folks over there at Wellstone.
And then also general medical concerns like if they take your blood and turns out you
have a very high glucose then you are going to be given a an appointment with the folks
at Happy Medical who are also there on site to get that taken care of.
So they're not going to let you walk out you know with the with a problem without at least
getting you an appointment to have that issue dealt with.
So it's really good to see the amount of the general public that was on hand and the the
seemingly good time that they were having despite what brought them there in the first
place.
So that was a privilege to see the neighborhood nursing program at UAH really start to crank
out and do some of that mission work that they have tasked themselves with.
Also had the pleasure of attending the Oakwood University's Blue and Gold Scholarship Gala
where I was able to present the new president Dr. Gina Brown with an allocation from the
District 5 Council Improvement Fund.
So we helped add to the scholarship fund there at Oakwood University and it's always a great
night of music and camaraderie and fellowship.
And want to invite folks to this year's 2026 Innovation Showcase at Columbia High School.
On Monday April 13th we're going to feature the 9th and 10th grade Trail Blazers and then
on Tuesday April 14th we're going to feature the 11th and 12th grade visionaries.
The times are from 830 a.m. to 330 p.m. each day so come on out and witness the next generation
of Huntsville's leaders, thinkers and creators.
And we'll have incredible presentations, interactive demonstrations and plenty of I knew them when
moments.
Thank you Madam President.
Thank you Mr. DeRette.
We will hear next from Councilmember Michelle Watkins.
Good evening everyone.
On this past Saturday at the Boys and Girls Club on Pulaski Pike we had a Stop the Violence
rally which is focused on our youth.
We had a good showing, had good representation.
I was really satisfied with the calls that I received.
People were really impressed.
This is only the beginning.
We're not going to stop.
Next month we're going to have a rally to talk about drug awareness.
So if you're in District 1 or any other district and these topics interest you, please come
out and support us.
Our youth need us at this time.
I want to thank Ricky Wilson, James Gossett and the Shower Center staff for coming out
on Monday.
We had a meeting at the Shower Center to talk about if we were going to renovate the Shower
Center or if we were going to build a new Shower Center.
And the consensus when we left was remodel.
So thank you Ricky.
You were very thorough.
I really appreciate everything you did.
There was a rumor running around town and people were getting calls at the city as well
as I was getting calls that we were going to change the name of the Shower Center.
I don't know where that started.
That conversation never happened here at the city, not between the mayor and council members,
no one.
So the Shower Center name is going to be the same.
It's going to stay where it's at.
That conversation never happened.
Want to thank Parks and Rec staff for supporting the Easter egg hunt in District 1.
Think it was their 10th year.
Parks and Rec did a lot of support and I want to thank you for doing that.
It's an Easter egg hunt that Yolanda Denson and several people started.
But I want to thank you for your support as well as I want to thank Parks and Rec and
the Shower Center for supporting Happy Comes, the Easter Bunny Comes to Happy Health at
the Shower Center.
They had an Easter egg hunt as well.
So I really want to give a big shout out to Parks and Rec because you exemplify what a
Parks and Rec office should be doing for the community being involved and I appreciate
that.
Lastly, I think that's it.
That's all I got.
Thank you.
Thank you, Ms. Watkins.
We will now hear from Council Member Bill Clean.
Thank you, Madam President.
I think all of us on the council have gotten input, comments, concern, questions about
the acquisition merger of Crestwood Hospital by Huntsville Hospital.
A lot of information and rumors have been out as far as what would have happened and
what hasn't happened.
The council, the full council had arranged for the CEO of Crestwood, excuse me, of Huntsville
Hospital to come down.
He's going to be at the April 23rd meeting and of course if you're watching this, you're
streaming it or watching it on cable TV or you're in the audience, you know it's available.
But anyway, because of that community interest, we appreciate the CEO of Huntsville Hospital,
Mr. Sam's coming down and again he's going to be making a presentation and I think providing
some very good information.
Another issue that perhaps I have dealt with, I don't know if other council members have
seen, but as I walked around neighborhoods throughout the district, I've become more
aware and started Archer Park and then I just kind of looked at more and more and more of
these damaged cable TV boxes, cable boxes, cable TV, fiber, different types are kicked
over, they're rusted, they may work, they may not work, but they're definitely an eyesore
and they're in neighborhoods throughout the district and I'm pretty sure throughout the
city based upon what I'm hearing.
I've talked with our esteemed, well let me rephrase that, I have talked to our city attorney,
Mr. Riley and Mr. Riley is looking into it and this is not pinning you up on anything
but can you just kind of tell what your thoughts are, where we are, where you would see this
going and just whatever you would like to say.
Keep in mind this is basically the top of the first inning of this so there's nothing
definitive that's been decided yet.
That's right.
Thank you, Councilman Cleen.
Of course the subject you talk about, dangling wires, ill-kept or abandoned communication
boxes and things is sort of a bane that we experience all over the city.
I look out my front door and I see some boxes that are not properly taken care of.
I see a cord that has been connected and has been running across the street and across
the yard for months on end and of course with grass mowing season coming on it sort of impacts
me how I'm going to take care of that.
It is a problem that I'm personally familiar with and I think is across all the city.
In fact, through the years many people have complained to city officials and obviously
to city council members as well about the commission of those facilities and things
adjacent to their homes.
Typically they're located in the city's rights of way which gives us a particular interest
in how things look including our public utility easements.
In 2020 the city council in an effort to address these things passed a comprehensive police
power ordinance that governs communication facilities in our rights of way.
That ordinance addresses among other things construction standards when we're putting
things in our right of way, restoration of property as a result of installing those things,
conditions of use including proper maintenance of the facilities when they may get hit by
a car and knocked over or there's service work going on and the lids don't get put
on properly and those things in the right of way.
So those things are there as well as abandoned facilities.
Oftentimes what happens when you have these dangling wires is someone will change their
service and the new service will come in, they'll just cut the wire and leave it dangling
or tangled up against the port or whatever, the pole or whatever and then put their own
in and so you have that and that develops and continues to bound up over the years.
That ordinance had several enforcement methods including prosecution in the municipal court,
stop work orders, in other words if they fail to do what they're supposed to do we can issue
a stop work order on other things that the communication companies are doing and permit
revocation for instance if they get a permit to do some of this.
These all are effective to some degree but they are also ineffective.
For instance in municipal court they're just not equipped for instance to cite and potentially
jail or whatever a corporation like AT&T, they're used to dealing with individuals.
So that turns out not to be a very effective method for us.
Stop work orders are not effective if they don't have any work order ongoing at the time
and permit revocation again is only effective when they're trying to obtain a revocation.
So those methods have some lack of effectiveness.
A more effective method that we've been utilizing and a more informal one has been to develop
a more cooperative relationship with our communication providers.
Our city ITS department is spearheading that effort and they're making a very coordinated
effort through our C-Click fix and other communications with the city to address each of those and
to get with those providers to address citizen complaints in a timely fashion.
Admittedly we don't always get the quick results that we would like to have but it is an effort
that does produce fruit from time to time and we continue to do it but once again the
problem is somewhat immense and there's not the manpower to address this as we would like.
Contractors have largely been responsive but they also don't necessarily have the resources
on hand to address the magnitude of the problems that exist and oftentimes their work is done
through third party contractors as well.
So this has been a frustrating experience for the city as well.
As a city attorney my job is to evaluate these tools that we have and try to address these
problems in as effective a manner as we can.
Frankly as we discussed all those tools are not available to us in all situations such
as I indicated when we're in the municipal court and we're not dealing with an individual
and sometimes the bang is not worth the buck.
In other words the expense involved with pursuing a remedy that would be effective is more expensive
than necessary.
But we have a methodology that when compliance arises to a certain level such as when public
safety is implicated or when there are repeat violations of our ordinances that we can seek
to obtain what's called injunctive relief through the circuit court.
That is a relief or a methodology that we've used in other areas and we are exploring it
at this time and we will continue to do so.
We ask for the continued patience of the citizens as we work to solve this thorny problem and
it's a difficult problem but we're doing the best we can and we'll try to do better.
Thank you sir.
Thank you Madam President.
Thank you Mr. Kling.
Thank you Mr. Riley.
We will now hear from Councilmember David Little.
Thank you Madam President.
This Saturday the Boston Wood Valley Civic Association will be hosting a biscuit breakfast
at the 9 o'clock at the Cornerstone Presbyterian Church and we'll have fire trucks and the
police will be there to talk about summer safety things and other items that I think
our residents will be interested in.
And then reminder April 30th out in the Cove area we'll be hosting a town hall at the
residence at Well Point.
I believe that's at 5 o'clock.
We'll have Dr. Sutton and Holly McCarty from the school system.
I believe Shane Davis will be there and County Commissioner Hill just to talk about what's
happening in the Cove.
And then just like to give a special shout out to Chris McNeese who's gone with me on
a couple of meetings with some residents to talk about some road issues.
It was very helpful on that and then as always thanks to HPD, the engineering department,
Huntsville utilities and public works being responsive to citizen needs.
Thank you.
I have a point of order here.
You did not invite the gentleman from the troop to come up and introduce themselves
like I thought was your role.
Was.
Yeah.
You do it all the time.
I was planning to do.
Oh well I'm sorry for stealing your thunder.
I'm just so used to Mr. Little doing that.
Sorry.
I'll be happy to.
On that note, let me again welcome the members of Scout Troop 361.
We are glad to have you here.
We know you're probably working on badges.
Could we have each member of the troop come up and give us their name, their rank and
if you're working on a badge, tell us what badge you're working on.
And many thanks as well to Noah for leading our pledge.
It's a scary thing when some lady you don't know comes up to you and asks you to get up
and like that give a pledge in front of all these people you don't know.
Hello.
My name is Noah Hitchcock.
I'm a life scout from Troop 361.
And you're here to work on a badge tonight?
Yes ma'am.
Which badge are you working on?
We're working on communication and citizenship in the community.
Very good.
Thank you.
And thank you again for helping us with the pledge Noah.
My name is Daniel Olenek.
I'm a life scout and tonight I'm working on communications and citizenship in the community.
Thank you.
My name is Anna Kolthoff and I'm actually from Troop 321.
I just tagged along with Troop 361.
And I am first class rank and I am working on communication and citizenship in the work
in the communities.
Very good.
Thank you.
And scout leaders, would you like to introduce yourselves?
You're doing really, really important work by leading these young people and helping
them develop their leadership skills.
I'm Benjamin Hitchcock, one of the assistant scout masters of Troop 361.
That's why you volunteered Noah.
The dad does it.
Okay.
I'm BJ Olenek.
I'm the advancement chair for Troop 361.
Good.
Thank you.
And I'm Kyle Kolthoff.
I'm an assistant scout master at both 321 and 361.
So I've got a son in 361 and a daughter in 321.
Wonderful.
Thank you again for joining us.
Thank you for the work you're doing.
And speaking of scouts, I had the opportunity last week to take, give a city hall tour to
Cub Scout pack number 73.
It was really fun taking them around and there was a whole lot of ooing and awing, but I'll
tell you what impressed them the most.
We had did kind of an impromptu visit down to EMA and they got to see the places where
in a disaster our folks would be able to sleep and take showers and eat and they thought
that was so cool.
So we love all our scouts.
I had the opportunity this weekend to attend the Chalk Festival, Southeastern Huntsville
Maine sponsored the second annual Chalk Festival.
We saw chalk creations of all kinds and all skill levels.
Had a great turnout, really nice weather, food trucks, vendors.
It was a great event and I applaud Southeastern Huntsville Maine for taking that on.
We just want to see it get bigger and better over the years.
I'm also looking forward to opening day.
I actually got to do a walk through a Bell Mountain Park with the Liberty League board
members to look at some issues there.
We made an extensive list of some things that needed to be addressed in advance of opening
day and I want to thank everybody at Landscape and at Parks and Rec, particularly James Gossett
and Scott Stapler and others who have worked to get the parks ready for opening day and
to address some of those issues.
It will be a great day and I will be there.
I don't know that I will be thrown out of pitch but I will be there to cheer everybody
else on.
On May 9th, Ditto Landing will host the annual cleanup day at Ditto Landing and we are so
grateful for the Southeast YMCA who are partners in this.
It will start at 8 o'clock in the morning so be there early.
There will be opportunities to cut down limbs, to pick up trash, to paint stripes in the
parking lot.
There really are jobs for everybody at every age.
It's a great project for Scouts.
We always have Scouts that come so that's May 9th.
Be sure and join us for that.
And then finally, Godspeed to the Artemis crew.
Our prayers for a safe splashdown and that's it.
We will now move on to Finance Committee Report 14A is a resolution authorizing expenditures
for payment.
I move for authorization and approval of expenses in the amount of $22,979,835.16.
Motion from the Chair.
All in favor please indicate aye.
Any opposed?
Motion carries.
Is there a report from the committee?
No, no ma'am.
14B is an ordinance approving appropriations, goods and services for District 2 Council
Improvement Funds.
Motion for Mr. Little.
Second.
Second for Mr. Meredith.
Mr. Little, can you share with us what you're planning to do here?
Thank you Madam President.
This is a $5,000 appropriation to the Alabama Center of Military History.
Our Veterans Museum is more commonly referred to to provide a little funding for development
and improvement of their educational displays.
Thank you.
Any comments from Council Members?
All in favor please indicate aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
We have no Board appointments to be voted on.
16A has been deleted by the sponsor.
We'll go on to 16B.
Madam President.
16B is a nomi- yes sir.
Oh, sorry.
We'll take nominations from the Board.
16B is a nomination to reappoint Mark McDaniel to the Education Building Authority Madison
Academy to his current seat for a six-year term to expire November 12, 2029.
Again, these are nomination only.
Action will be taken at the April 23rd Council Meeting.
16C is a nomination to reappoint Robert Burton to the Education Building Authority Madison
Academy to his current seat for a six-year term to expire November 10, 2031.
The floor is now open for- we'll now take nominations from the floor.
Mr. Klein.
Madam President, I'd like to nominate Ed Banville for the vacancy created by the expiration
of the term of David Driscoll on the BINGO Committee.
Thank you.
Are there any other nominations?
None.
We'll move on then to number 17, Huntsville Utility Item 17A is a resolution authorizing
the Mayor to approve the sale of surplus property on Gillespie Road in Madison, Alabama to the
Water and Wastewater Board of the City of Madison doing business as Madison Utilities
at a sales price of $1 million.
Is there a motion to approve?
Motion to approve.
Motion from Mr. Mayor.
Second.
Second from Mr. Little.
Do we have a presentation from Huntsville Utilities?
Yeah.
Hey, good evening.
Chris Jones, Huntsville Utilities.
No presentation, just a couple of quick comments.
This is property that was used by our electric department from 1996 through 2016.
And then from 2016 through 2024 by our fiber group, we relocated that group to another
location primarily due to traffic as Madison grew, became very difficult to get our crews
out of that location.
The City of Madison would like to purchase the property.
It's a good fit for them.
They don't have to travel as far.
So the million dollar purchase price was a result of a couple of appraisals, one performed
by a contractor on our side, one by the City of Madison.
So we think that represents fair market value and I'd be happy to answer any questions.
Thank you.
Any questions?
All right, very good.
Apparently you did a good job.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed?
Motion carries.
We have a couple of, or one legal item.
18A is an ordinance authorizing the vacation of the utility and drainage easement in the
Huntsville North Village Phase 1A North Village Boulevard Northwest.
Is there a motion to approve?
Motion to approve.
Second.
Second for Mr. Meredith.
Any discussion?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed?
Motion carries.
Unfinished items for business.
19A is an ordinance amending Chapter 2 Article 4 Division 2 Section 2-184 of Ordinance 96-864
to establish a formal policy to exempt expenditures for repair parts and the repair of light duty
vehicles with a gross vehicle weight of 12,000 pounds or less from the competitive bidding
process.
Is there a motion to approve?
Motion to approve.
Second.
Motion for Mr. Little.
Second for Mr. Meredith.
Any discussion?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed?
Motion carries.
19B is an ordinance declaring certain equipment surplus be sold at public auction.
Is there a motion to approve?
Motion for Mr. Little.
Second.
Second for Mr. Meredith.
Any discussion?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed?
Motion carries.
We move on now to new business items for consideration.
Members, you have told me that you would like to hold items D, F, I, M, N, P, and R. Are
there any other items to be held?
D, F, I, M, N, P, and R.
Anybody have anything else?
Chair moves for consolidation and approval of items 20A to C, 20E, 20G, 20H, 20J, 2L,
20N, 20Q, and 20S and T. Is there a second?
Second.
All in favor, indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed?
Motion carries.
We will now move on to consider each individual item.
We will begin with 20D.
20D is a resolution authorizing the Mayor to enter into a consulting agreement between
the City of Huntsville and Bold Agency LLC for graphic design support and web development
services.
Is there a motion to approve?
Motion to approve.
Motion from Mr. Mayor, second from the Chair.
Ms. Rice.
Hello.
Good evening.
My name is Carrie Rice.
I'm a communication specialist with the City of Huntsville.
Council members, item 20D is the annual professional services contract renewal with Bold Agency
for website design and large branding projects with a not to exceed amount of $100,000.
Exceeding this amount includes the design and development of our new city website, which
will launch later this year.
It also includes design work for any large city branding projects, Central Sports District,
John Hunt Park, Sandra Moon, and others.
And if you have any questions, I'd be happy to answer them.
Any questions for Ms. Rice?
I have a question.
Ms. Watkins.
Good evening.
How you doing?
So you said large branding.
Would it be any branding like if City Council needs flyers or anything done like that?
Would that be able to be to do that for us?
Absolutely.
Yes.
Okay.
Thank you.
Just let us know.
Anyone else?
All in favor, please indicate.
I oppose.
Motion carries.
Thank you.
Move on to 20F.
20F is a resolution authorizing the use of the DS200 precinct electronic voting devices
and the ADA express vote machines in the municipal general election and runoff election if necessary.
Motion to...
To approve.
Motion for Mr. Meredith.
Second.
Second by Mr. Little.
Ms. Edwards.
Good evening, Council, Mayor Battle, Shandrick Edwards, City Clerk.
This resolution is authorizing the use of the DS200 precinct electronic voting devices
and the ADA express vote machine in the upcoming municipal general election and runoff if necessary.
This machine is the device that does all of our reporting, counting, excuse me, and tabulating
for our election results for all of our elections.
Moving forward, this will stay in place for any subsequent elections.
I'll be glad to answer any questions.
Questions for Ms. Edwards.
Ms. Merritt.
What's the difference between a count and a tabulation?
Essentially, it's the same.
Okay.
I just wanted to make sure I didn't miss something.
It's the definition they use for the machine.
It's essentially the same.
Is it the last time we did a canvassing here, you brought out a machine, is that-
That is the DS200 that we utilize from Madison County.
Okay.
So that's what we're talking about.
That is the DS200.
Correct.
And the only change here, that's the same machine we've been using for a number of years.
The reason I did this is because the ADA machine was previously known as an auto mark machine
and it is now known as an express vote machine.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
Any other questions?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
Thank you, Ms. Edwards.
20 aye.
Is a resolution authorizing the mayor to execute renewal number two to the lease agreement
between the city of Huntsville and WizKids LLC for the lease of a portion of property?
Chair moves for approval.
Second.
Second by Mr. Meredith and Mr. Wilkinson.
Yes.
Good evening.
Ricky Wilkinson, director of general services.
So this is the second renewal to a lease agreement with WizKids.
This renewal will take effect July 1st of 2026.
It's a one year extension to June 30th of 2027.
It does include for the original lease agreement, a 3% escalation in the rent cost, which brings
that total to $6,013.33 a month.
I'm happy to answer any questions.
Questions for Mr. Wilkinson.
Anybody have questions?
All those in favor, please indicate by saying aye.
Any opposed?
Motion carries.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr. Wilkinson.
20 am is a resolution authorizing the mayor to enter into agreement between the city of
Huntsville and ParkZen.
Chair moves for approval.
Second.
Second by Mr. Meredith.
Ms. Bryant, welcome back.
Good evening again.
Keisha Bryant, director of parking and public transit.
The item before you for consideration is to enter into an agreement with ParkZen.
ParkZen provides a data driven approach to parking.
This hardware free technology would be a standalone mobile application that has capability to
provide real time parking availability along with corresponding way finding to get you
to that parking location that has available parking.
With this, we would be able to assist our parkers in locating available parking more
efficiently.
Our department would also benefit from the analytics that the application will provide
to us as we look for ways to optimize our operations and plan for the future.
This contract covers a one time implementation fee of $10,000 and an annual subscription
fee of $15,000.
Any comments or questions?
I will make one comment.
I have heard over the years repeatedly people saying there's no parking downtown, we don't
have enough parking downtown, but then parking people say we have parking, this will just
help people find it.
That's right.
It's there.
We just need to help them find it.
I promise.
Thank you.
I do have a question.
Yes.
Okay, the $10,000 implementation fee, why is that?
So the implementation fee is the app actually has to be developed to take into account all
of the parking that we have in the city of Huntsville.
So what they do is they tailor the app to meet our needs and so they would have to geofence
all of our parking garages and parking lots and put that into the app that would be specifically
for Huntsville.
That's a one time fee.
Okay.
Thank you.
Yes.
Any other questions?
Mr. Mayor?
Is there a fee to end users?
No.
There is not a fee to end users.
It's its own freestanding app so they have to go in there and download that.
That's correct.
The users would have to download the app to utilize it and once we get it developed and
ready to launch, we will share that with the community so that they know it's out there
and hopefully lots of people will take advantage of it.
And hopefully this never happens but if there's an issue, then they need to yell at the developer
of this app and not city of Huntsville, correct?
We'll direct them to the proper person to complain to.
Thank you very much.
And you'll also take that feedback into account.
Any other questions?
All in favor, please indicate aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
Thank you very much, Ms. Bryant.
20N is resolution authorizing the mayor to enter into a cooperative agreement between
the city of Huntsville, the United States Department of Justice and the Drug Enforcement
Administration.
Is there a motion to approve?
Motion to approve.
Mr. Mayor, second from Mr. Little.
Mr. Hamilton?
Good evening, Council Members.
John Hamilton, City Administrator.
What's before you is renewal of the existing MOU that we've had with DEA and the Department
of Justice specific to drug trafficking.
So we provide officers into their offices and they provide officers into our regional
task force.
And so this is just a renewal of that agreement.
Questions for Mr. Hamilton?
I do.
Ms. Markins.
Does this have anything to do with ICE?
It does not.
Will you be assisting ICE in picking up citizens?
This, some of you, has nothing to do with that.
So as we've talked about before, so separate from this, obviously, if there's a war for
somebody's arrest, oftentimes local law enforcement assists ensuring that those operations, whether
it's the FBI or any other federal agency, does that in a safe manner.
Is this agreement in place where if ICE comes to town, you assist ICE?
This in no way facilitates that.
Okay.
Thank you.
I have a question regarding over policing in some areas of town.
Is this going to be used to provide law enforcement across the city?
Is it actually, it's a regional task force.
So we have agencies, local, state, and federal agencies from across North Alabama that are
all partners in this fight.
And so they're going to go to wherever the crime is.
So there is no targeting involved?
No.
Thank you.
Any other questions, comments?
I think...
Mr. Cling?
I think I saw that.
Make sure your microphone.
I believe I saw one of the police reports, police department annual reports that very
general we can say that drug is a drug problem throughout the city.
It's not one part of the city.
The district I represent east of the Parkway, west of the Parkway, I looked at and it's
pretty prevalent on both sides.
And what I saw in that report, it's pretty much widespread throughout the city.
And unfortunately drugs do not have any limitations.
They seem to go all over the place.
So that would kind of back that up.
And I think, you know, obviously we put a lot of effort into, you know, in this particular
area, there's obviously different task forces spoke on different types of crime.
One of the things that we see in the drug networks is that other crime comes from that.
There's other violence, other things.
You see rivalries between networks and things that generate violent crime and things.
So you ultimately this is a big part of making a safe on multiple levels.
Any more questions?
Thank you, Mr. Hamilton.
All in favor, please indicate.
I mean, pose the motion carries.
We will go to 20 P 20 P is resolution authorizing mayor to enter into an agreement between city
of Huntsville and Crimson recruiting services LLC for police officer recruitment.
Is there a motion to approve motion to Mr. Mayor?
It's second for Mr. Little.
Mr. Hamilton.
Council members, what's before you, I think is really the start of what will be a continuing
conversation on a number of things that we need to do to ensure that we are recruiting
and attracting a highly qualified workforce within our police department.
You know, that also applies to other departments, but in particular focused on ensuring that
our police department has the resources they need and the manpower and highly skilled,
highly qualified, properly trained manpower is obviously critical to the work that we
do throughout your districts.
But that's getting that workforce is particularly challenging.
And there's another part of things that we're doing to try to assist with that that we'll
continue to bring to you over the coming council meetings.
But what this is is specifically a service that we have in collaboration with other cities
in Alabama.
They have used a particularly mobile to great success in assisting and finding good candidates
to bring into our police academy.
So this would be a new relationship.
So that would really rely on the experience they've had and the success that they've
demonstrated in South Alabama, bring that here and assist us in the recruiting effort.
We have full time staff inside the police department that works that effort.
And we believe we really need to increase that effort and the success that this particular
company has shown in partnership with mobile is something that we want to bring to you.
So we recommend approval on this contract.
Questions for Mr. Hamilton?
Mr. Merida?
Yes.
What's their expertise?
What are they going to do that our current local folks aren't doing?
So what we've seen, you know, their demonstrated capability is really the manner in which they
market and they've been particularly effective in, you know, not everybody's cut out to be
a police officer, you know, and the types of folks that we find that come in and are
very successful and high quality police officers.
They've demonstrated a particular skill in just marketing to that particular unique segment
of our population and have a number of kind of marketing pages.
This is really a marketing campaign is what it is, but they have shown to be particularly
adept at going after those particular types of folks.
National basis or regional basis?
We certainly try to market nationally, you know, and there is some success and particularly
later on in the agenda there is an item to assist us in going after folks that are already
police officers elsewhere and interested in moving.
So that's probably where you see the most success in a national marketing campaign.
We've had some success like that.
We have some great officers in our force right now that came here from Chicago and places
in Arizona and California and other States.
So we've had some success, but you're kind of talking onesies, twosies in those particular
cases.
So certainly we want to push nationally as best we can.
Nationally speaking, folks aren't moving across the country for that job.
If you want to be a police officer, there's one in every community, right?
So there's opportunity.
So we certainly will take every single person that we can that's properly qualified to do
the job.
Your real bang for your buck in terms of the volume you need is going to be local.
It's going to be within our region, within our State or within a certain driving distance.
And so we will focus most of our efforts where we're going to expect to get the greatest
return on our investment.
But of course, in today's world, a website goes around the world, right?
And social media goes around the world.
And that's where I think the way in which we sell our community and the quality of our
department is why we attract some of those folks.
But I think really kind of the point you're getting at is your greatest success is going
to be within a certain radius around the community.
And finally, what do we have any target recruitment goals for them?
Meaning do we expect them to recruit 200 workers in the next year or, you know?
Well, I'll tell you right now, just the positions the council has authorized us versus what
we have filled, we have about 75 vacancies.
And so we are working hard to fill every single academy class.
Generally speaking, what we can take at any one time will be in the kind of mid-30s is
what the academy can handle.
And so two sessions per year.
So far we've not been successful and come anywhere near that number.
So you've seen some of our graduating classes of 8 or 10 or 12.
And so it's something that we've got to identify ways of getting better at bringing people
in.
Now some of that also is competitive compensation packages.
And so we're doing studies regionally, particularly just how we compare that.
And I think there's some things, the work that we need to do to assist with that.
And that's what I'm referring to when I say we're going to probably bring you some additional
things in the near future to try and address some of those concerns throughout our public
safety, not only police but also the fire department.
But obviously tonight we're focused on the police.
So the reality is if I could get 75 folks in the academy tomorrow, I'd do it.
But the academy couldn't handle it.
And quite frankly, we have not generally found that number of highly qualified folks.
It is a very, very selective process.
Every time we advertise, every academy will get several hundred applicants.
And oftentimes of that 10 to 20 are actually of the quality, the capability that we're
looking for.
So it is a tough, tough cut.
And so we've got to continue to get more of those highly qualified folks.
Thank you very much.
Any other questions?
Ms. Warkin.
I see on the notes it says that we may extend for two additional 12-month terms.
Is that correct?
So that means for two additional years?
So those would be if we choose to do so.
So that's pretty typical.
A lot of our contracts like this, we'll do one year but have the option to do extensions
if in fact we're having success.
This is the first time we've gone to an outside entity to partner with us.
And so while we have seen great success in the work they did down in Mobile, Huntsville
and Mobile aren't exactly the same.
And so if it's something as we get through it that it's not working the way we need it
to, then we would not renew that contract.
If it's working great and we think it's worth the investment, then we would continue.
So would you say like if they improve the hiring like by 25% there would be a success
rate that you would want to continue with?
I certainly wouldn't.
I think it's hard.
You don't want to put the exact number on it.
But I agree with the premise there that you're putting forward that we've got to see a return
on investment.
Absolutely.
That's really what I was concerned about, just making sure we are seeing a return on
our investment.
Absolutely.
I agree.
Thank you, Mr. Hamilton.
And those extensions would come to the Council for a relative period.
Any other questions?
All in favor, please indicate aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
20R is a resolution authorizing the Mayor to enter into a solar ground lease agreement
by and among the City of Huntsville and Madison County, Alabama as landlord and EE Gemini
Solar LLC as tenant and authorizing Mayor to sign additional documents related there
to.
Motion to approve.
Motion from Mr. Mayor.
Second.
Second from Mr. Kling.
Mr. Davis.
Good evening, Council Mayor.
Thank you, Madam President.
So tonight what we bring you is a tripartite agreement, really a quad-party agreement between
the City of Huntsville, Madison County Commission, Huntsville Utilities, and URUS, Inc., or Gemini
Solar LLC.
So what I wanted to bring you is a vicinity map, as you can see on the screen.
The pink square there is near the intersection of 6th Street and Wall Trana.
So that is property that has been on for probably 30 plus years.
It's jointly on between the City of Huntsville and the Madison County Commission.
It was purchased many years ago as a potential industrial site or for industrial use to benefit
the holistic community, meaning City of Huntsville and Madison County.
I want to go through some details of this lease agreement.
The County Commission passed the same document that's before you tonight earlier this week.
So what we would do in partnership with Madison County and Huntsville Utilities is enter into
a ground lease, so we're not selling the property, the public remains the owners of the property,
of 237 acres to generate a new 40 megawatt solar facility, very significant local power
generation in a very green manner.
The lease term would be for 35 years.
At the end of that term, we would have two options, you know, a future council and a
future County Commission could renew and extend and continue to generate power there.
If we chose not to do so, all the solar facility that would be on the property would have to
be removed and the property returned to its natural state.
So there is a revenue stream attached to that.
So should you approve this tonight, they'll start their due diligence period and then
get into what we refer to as a development period.
That's actual construction in this document, we see development period.
So once construction starts, they have 14 months to complete and be generating power.
So we, during that construction period, have asked for a partial payment of the annual
lease in the amount of $23,796 and then upon completion and it generating power, there
is an annual lease payment of $237,690 per year.
We will split those proceeds 50-50 with a county.
Huntsville utilities is here tonight, who is the backbone of this project.
So if you would like to know more about the solar and its generation and how it comes
onto our grid, I can tell you from where I sit in City Hall of Industrial Development
and Economic Development and some of the long-term goals that TVA is working on and people like
Eli Lilly coming in and Space Command and the growth of the FBI and Redstone Arsenal,
the proximity to our grid in Redstone Arsenal, this is a great solution for our community,
especially not only for the next 35 years, but there's about a three to five year window
where adding this local generation to our overall power grid helps strengthen this community
as far as our future and continued growth and being able to manage that and manage cost.
I think Wes Kelly, when he come for this council, talked about the five goals and one of those
was local power generation, which keeps our rates low.
This is a prime example of that.
So I'll defer, answer any questions you have about the lease, but as far as the project,
Chris Jones is here with Huntsville Utilities.
Questions, Mr. Mayor.
Yes, I got one for Huntsville Utilities.
Where is this going to tie in?
I know there's a substation up Wall Triana, but that's the one I'm familiar with.
Is there another one that this is possibly going to tie in?
I'll let Mr. Jones.
Thank you, Mr. Davis.
Yeah, good evening again.
Chris Jones, Chief Operating Officer, Huntsville Utilities.
So there is an existing 46 kV transmission line that runs along Wall Triana that connects
to the substation for our water treatment plant and it also goes north and eventually
connects to Jetport substation.
So we'll build a new substation tying to that transmission line and the energy will go back
to Jetport.
Okay, awesome.
Thank you.
That was it.
No, ma'am.
Just a general comment.
This is what I understand about this is kind of complicated.
You've got Huntsville Utilities, City of Huntsville, working with Madison County Commission, they
did their thing.
And in this era of what we see nationally, it's just nice that we see that local city
governing bodies and agencies can work together for the public good.
That's the only way it happens out in the West, my friend, is you've got to have collaboration.
And kudos and a shout out to TVA.
They changed their policy a few years ago.
So what they refer to is people like Huntsville Utilities is co-ops, cooperatives, and their
policy forbid or prohibited any local power generation by their cooperatives.
So Huntsville Utilities could not have done this project.
But they see how they need to be reactive and proactive and change some of their policies.
And certainly they want a green power mix across their entire portfolio, certainly the
hydro power and the nuclear power.
They're doing some of their own solar.
But to allow the cooperatives, people like Huntsville Utilities, to go do projects like
this, we've completed one, North Huntsville Industrial Park, in partnership with Toyota.
Athens Electric and TVA are working on a major project, very similar, at Mazda Toyota in partnership
with them.
So one, I think it's great for our community, show diversity in how we generate power, but
also the resiliency that we'll bring to our community.
Anybody else have questions?
I do have one question, and that is, who is EEG M&I Solar LLC?
Is that an entity created by Huntsville Utilities?
It's actually created by their business partner who operate, so it's the same company, so
that Huntsville Utilities did an RFP, so a very competitive process.
So it's actually Eurus Inc.
They are actually a parent company of Toyota, or they were birthed out of there.
They're a for-profit standalone company, but they won that.
They've done about as much solar as anybody across the U.S., so very experienced.
And that RFP process actually had a competitive component in it in what that power generation
of those solar panels, what that power could be generated and purchased for.
So the cheaper we can purchase, the better it passes on to our rate customer, and that's
how they were selected.
So that's another layer of partnership for you there.
Very good.
Any other comments?
One last question.
Will this have any effect on rates?
Will this take any rates up?
No, no.
So the capital investment that is being made here will have no bearing on the rates.
I don't want to speak for Huntsville Utilities, but talking with Wes Kelly, deploying projects
like this, so Huntsville Utilities' self-generating power actually helps us long-term stabilize
our local rate.
You want to add to that?
Sure.
I can just say, based on our experience with the solar facility at Toyota, the energy costs
that we will purchase will be lower than what we purchase from TVA.
We also experience demand savings, so we expect this to be – we will have some capital investment
to build a substation, but we expect the payback to be probably two years or less, and there
will be money savings after that.
Thank you.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
Thank you, Council Members.
Thank you, Mr. Davis.
Thank you, Mr. Jones.
We move to new items for introduction.
These items are for introduction only, and they will be considered at a later meeting.
Sorry?
I guess just for the record, on item 21A –
Could I read it first?
If you would let me introduce it, and then we'll talk about it.
21A is the introduction – because we don't have anything to talk about yet.
21A is the introduction of an ordinance renaming the portion of Cleveland Avenue from Meridian
Street to Church Street to Microwave Day Way.
So it has been properly introduced, Mr. Kling.
It would be my request that the Council – and this is actually at the request of the family
and foundation group – that they like to have this held over until May 14th for passage,
as there's going to be a special event the following Sunday at the Civic Center.
And for that reason, we would like to ask.
Also a concern was raised about the street naming.
For me, before this even was something on my radar, I was approached by numerous people
from the Microwave Day Foundation and family.
And they, along with the six business owners that would be impacted by this, they lobbied
me and they asked that this be done.
It wasn't like I went out to do it and this was going to change some things.
But the people who would be impacted with their business addresses requested that this
be done.
Also, if I can veer a little bit –
Hang on.
We need to just really focus on what we're doing here.
So from what I understand, we have the family coming on May 14th to accept a resolution.
And so you are asking that rather than having this considered as would be our normal practice
at the next council meeting April 23rd, you would like to postpone consideration until
the May 14th meeting.
Have you made that motion?
I would so move.
And Mr. Little will second it.
So now, is there any question, comments regarding this motion to postpone to the May 14th meeting?
Is that kosher with bylaws and Robert's rules or do we need to actually make this motion
at the next meeting?
To me, I looked at it briefly this afternoon and I saw nothing that would make it impossible
or illegal for us to simply set the consideration of this matter at that next meeting.
Not the next meeting, but the one after.
I get it.
It's just that since this was for introduction only, we shouldn't really be having this
discussion.
We should be asking for can we actually be voting on something pertaining to this, meaning
postponing.
I believe we're voting on the consideration.
And normally it would be considered at the April 23rd meeting, but we're asking to just
postpone to the May 14th meeting.
I see no problem with doing it.
Okay.
You know, because in every one of these, we would just as a matter of habit, we would
set it for the next meeting and we simply, there's a request being made that we set
it at the next one.
It's either way accomplishes the same thing.
There's a great deal of interest in this item.
I know a great deal of public interest and we just for the clarity sake, we're just going
to let everybody know that it will not be considered at the next meeting in deference
to the family.
It will be considered at the May 14th meeting.
Given what you have said, what Mr. Riley has said, I have no objection on voting on Mr.
Klain's motion.
So then all in favor of considering this item that has been properly introduced at the May
14th meeting, please say aye.
Aye.
Any opposed, motion carries.
We will consider that at the May 14th meeting.
21B is the introduction of an ordinance to name the dog park located at I-565 and Pratt
Avenue known as the downtown dog spot to the microwave day dog spot.
If I could.
So this has been properly introduced.
I just wanted to know it says city council is a sponsor.
Who actually is sponsoring?
I would be glad to be listed as the culprit, but I thought this might be something good
for the whole council.
I was just curious because we're running out of things to name after you, Mr. Klain.
Klain and I can co-sponsor it like we did the road.
That's fine.
It will be Mr. Klain and Mr. Little.
Is it going to be necessary also to postpone consideration to the May 14th meeting on this
item?
I believe so.
I believe we would just make a similar motion to postpone the introduction from the introduction
to the May 14th meeting.
Postpone for consideration to the May 14th meeting.
Second.
Mr. Little.
I believe we would just make a similar motion.
All in favor please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
The motion to postpone the properly introduced ordinance.
Carries.
There is a relationship between microwave day and the dog part, but you're going to have
to tune in on May 14th to find out.
You'll hear about it then.
Thank you.
Mr. Klain is so excited about this.
He just wants to tell everybody.
21C is the introduction of an ordinance to amend section 8.2 appointment rate of ordinance
04-315 personnel policies and procedures manual.
This will be considered at the April 23rd meeting.
I want to get some more.
21D is the introduction of an ordinance to amend ordinance number 89-79 classification
and salary plan ordinance.
21E is the introduction of an ordinance to amend the budget ordinance number 25-744 to
modify the authorized strength of departments.
21F is the introduction of an ordinance annexing 2.41 acres of land lying on the west side
of Old Big Cove Road and south of Whirly Drive.
21G is introduction of an ordinance to declare certain property as surplus and authorize
the mayor to enter into a purchase and sale agreement between the City of Huntsville and
Everett Properties Inc. for the purchase of the same.
And 21H is introduction of an ordinance declaring certain equipment surplus and to be sold
at public auction.
All those items will be considered at the April 23rd meeting.
This brings us now to second roster public comments.
This portion of the meeting is reserved for persons wishing to address the Council on
matters relating to City business, whether or not such items are on the meeting agenda.
Individuals have signed up on the roster prior to the meeting.
And when I call your name, approach the microphone, state your name, home address, and City of
residence, and I will call also the succeeding speakers so that you can be ready to come
up.
Each speaker may address the Council for three minutes.
Speakers shall refrain from entering into a dialogue with Council members or City staff
and from making comments regarding the good name and character of any individual.
The first person we will hear from is Angelica Condor, who will be followed by Julian Boykin.
Is Angelica Condor here?
And we will move on to Julian Boykin, who will be followed by Michael Francis.
If you'll just give those to Mr. Riley, Mr. Riley can make sure that we get them all.
Thank you, sir.
And you'll come to the microphone right there.
Name and address for the record.
Julian Boykin, 1107 Blackbriar Circle, Hartzell, Alabama, 35640.
Thank you, sir.
Good evening, Council members, Mayor Battle, my name is Julian Boykin.
I'm here to introduce a civic partnership vision called the Luminary, Alabama History Museum.
Alabama has an incredible historical assets, but no single institution tells our full multicultural
story from indigenous Alabama to the Civil Rights era, the space race, and the innovation
economy shaping our future.
Huntsville is the only city positioned to house that complete story.
The Luminary fills that statewide gap.
It's designed as a world class architectural iconic museum that aligns Huntsville's growth,
its tourism strength, and its identity as the rocket city.
I have two visual renderings that I want to present to the Council as well.
Sorry, sir, you're using up your time here.
So if you'll just continue your comments.
Thank you.
The museum's four level design ascends from Alabama's foundation to its future, echoing
Huntsville's spirit of launching bold ideas.
It also includes a K through 12 educational model aligned with Alabama standards and parental
choice, making it a statewide resource for families and schools.
The Luminary is not asking for funding.
We are seeking a partnership pathway, a concept endorsement, a designated city liaison, and
a collaboration on site identification with the I-65, I-565 gateway.
Huntsville has always led Alabama forward.
The Luminary is the next opportunity to do that.
Thank you for your time and for your service to the city.
Any questions?
Thank you, sir.
We appreciate your time.
Thank you.
We will now hear from Michael Francis.
Michael Francis will be followed by Howard Ross.
Is Michael Francis here?
We'll move on then.
Is Mr. Ross here?
Then we will hear from Mark Culberton.
Oh, here he comes.
Okay.
Mr. Ross.
Following Mr. Ross will be Mr. Ross, if you'll come to the microphone, please.
And then we will hear from Mark Culberton.
Is this Michael Francis?
Okay.
Well we'll hear first from Howard Ross and then we will hear from Mark Culberton.
Mark Culberton and then Howard Ross.
Mr. Culberton.
Yes, please, right up to the microphone.
And if you'll give us your name and address for the record and then you will have three
minutes.
Okay.
Hi, my name is Mark Culberton.
My address is 6016 Ellington Road in Huntsville, Alabama.
Earlier this year, about March 3rd or 4th, we decided we would go on vacation for a little
bit and we left our home.
After about three days of being at vacation, we get a phone call from a friend of ours
that said somebody's in our house.
So we called the police.
We had them go to the house.
A lady named Janet Hampton presents the police with some kind of paper that says she has
an order to evict me and my family, which was a lawful order.
But anyway, she tells the cops, so I called the cops and they told me that they're evicting
me and that I knew that I was supposed to be evicted and whatever.
But did I get an order?
But I didn't ever get an order.
I never got nothing.
And here's what the judge says about it.
On September 1, Janet Hampton filed a 14-day notice to vacate.
It was posted by law enforcement on February 25th, 2026.
The answer was adjudicated of this case.
Janet Hampton appears to have reclaimed the property, the supposed Mark Culberson's personal
property without agreement or notice to them.
After review, the statute court finds that the cause is not properly before this court
that under the Alabama Code section applies to this incident.
In other words, she's not my landlord.
She didn't have no right to go in my house and throw my stuff out.
So the police aided her in this.
And what I'm here to do is find out what I can do about it.
That concludes your comments, sir?
Yeah, well, I don't know what else to say.
One thing you need to know?
I have somebody in my house right now.
I have four kids and I have somebody staying in my house that ain't supposed to be in my
house at all.
And I'm living in a campground in your police department here in this city, Dunnett.
Thank you, sir.
So our police do not do evictions.
That's a sheriff's department issue.
Yes, ma'am.
I know who I called.
I called Huntsville City Cops and said, hey, these people are in my house.
Mr. Hamilton is going to have, we'll talk to you outside in the lobby.
So you can just talk one-on-one with Mr. Hamilton.
Why am I being cut off?
Because I'm talking about the police department.
Am I leaving today?
No, you have one minute left.
If you'd like to, you said you were finished.
Well, no, I want to know how this is going to go because me and my wife and kids have
already been thrown out of our house by this city.
Absolutely understand that.
And that's why we would like you to talk with Mr. Hamilton.
Okay.
He can provide you more information.
We'll now hear from Howard Ross.
Mr. Ross?
Yeah, Howard Ross, 2617 Excalibur Drive, Huntsville, and I'm just here to follow up on this because
while I'm not the victim, I was a witness because when I got to the property after I
was told what was going on, I also called the police department, spoke to dispatch,
told them that these people were trespassing and they were taking the property out of the
illegally removing property and possibly stealing it.
And police showed up and when I explained to them that the police said that while they
had a court order of eviction, I said that can't be because they gave them a notice and
there's a paperwork here saying that they're going to have a trial on March 24th so they
could not have had an order of eviction.
Someone is making it up and the police said, well, they got an order and we're not showing
it.
I asked to see it and they said, we're not going to show it to you.
You need to get out of here and we're letting them onto the property.
And in fact, I've even got something from two years ago when I boarded someone's house
up where I was the landlord and...
A local landlord is being told he cannot immediately evict his tenant.
And after that person's attempted arson arrest, Ezier Sanders, the man on your screen has
been in the Madison County Jail since Monday when police arrested him for attempted arson.
Police say he poured gasoline over himself and his wife during a domestic dispute.
Way 31's Nicole Zedek has been following this story since the property owner boarded up
the home Monday, which Nicole, he's now being told to undo.
Marie, actually only about an hour after our story aired, I got a call from the homeowner,
Howard Ross, and he said the police will get to take out those...
Mr. Ross, we don't usually let people play audio in here, so I think we've heard it.
Do you have any other comments?
Have you finished your comment?
When I went to evict someone, locked the door up, they said I couldn't do that.
The police may be letting the people back in the house, but I don't understand why...
Is that loud or murder?
This is a very difficult situation.
Yes, it is.
We understand that.
And so we're having Mr. Hamilton speak with the family to see what resolution we can find.
Okay.
Thank you, sir.
I appreciate it.
I think this is District 1, is the area that we need to also coordinate with the City Council
person from that.
That would be Ms. MacKenzie.
She can work with you.
Okay.
Thank you.
That would be the most effective way to handle this.
Thank you for making us aware.
We will now hear from Angela Somerset, who will be followed by Patty Culbertson.
Dr. Somerset?
Dr. Lucy Logan-Tie.
Okay.
All righty.
Well, good evening, everyone.
I am Dr. Angela Somerset.
And as always, again, I am-
Could you give us your address for the record?
I'm sorry.
I am at 9 Chalks, Stone Street.
In Huntsville.
Okay.
In Huntsville, Alabama.
That is correct.
Thank you.
And I am here again to talk about Huntsville Utilities.
It's going to be very brief.
Three things I've learned this week.
Freedom is not free.
Common sense is not common.
And transparency and accountability will cost you more than a tank of gas.
This past week, I've had so many citizens that reached out to me to answer questions that really should be answered by the board in Huntsville Utilities.
One of those would actually be the cubic feet for the gas.
Huntsville Utilities has not put the conversion factor in there.
It's in metered units.
You have to multiply it by 100.
And that's how you will actually come up with the equation.
One of the other concerns was a citizen, a great friend of mine, found this citizen that Huntsville Utilities told her that she had a $6,000 bill.
It was not her bill.
It was actually another tenant's.
So the lady, I'm trying to keep from saying her name, went home to the house that she had leased.
She had the keys.
She stayed in the house for one week during that coldest week in March with two children.
She asked Huntsville Utilities if they could give her some time.
She recognized that she had a past due balance, but not $6,000.
After that week, she talked to her landlord, who then graciously called Councilwoman Watkins, who then interceded.
Then it is my understanding that the landlord was then asked if he wanted to pay it. That's illegal.
You cannot ask someone to assume someone else's bill.
We have got to start delving into Huntsville Utilities a lot deeper than we are.
They are overspending in budgets.
Google Fiber was supposed to cost $57 million, and it's always an excuse.
We are there $50 million over.
There's got to be some resolution in regards to this.
That young lady, who is a single mother, was struggling to pay that bill.
At some point, Christianity has got to be more than just talk.
So a friend of mine and myself paid that lady's bill of $834.
There's got to be something with accountability.
We've got two of our council members up here, Dr. Robinson and Councilman Cline.
Actually, the young lady was in your district.
People are looking for answers that they are not getting.
We have board members.
If they don't understand metered units and how to make conversion factors, why are these people sitting on boards?
We've got a CEO with a Bachelor of Arts, and he's explaining us a heat pump?
But we're not explaining availability charges?
Or I live in Georgia, and my utility bill is $76 and a 2,200 square foot house that has a general rack and all of this.
It's got to stop. We have got to start delving deep.
Oh, lastly.
Thank you, Dr. Somerset.
Thank you.
We will now hear from Patty Cobritson, who will be followed by Molly Clark.
Hi, I'm Patty Cobritson. I'm at 601 6 Elleton, Huntsville.
And I just wanted everybody to know how that when we get kicked out, when we got kicked out and they took our stuff, how hard it is to live in a camper with three kids.
And we just wanted to see if we could get help from somebody and see which way to go.
I just didn't want to take up much time because you already sent my husband out to talk to them.
So I just want everybody to know how hard we have it right now.
Thank you all for listening.
It sounds like this has been a very difficult situation.
Thank you for coming and sharing it.
And we hope we really want to reach resolution. That's why we've asked you to meet with somebody one on one.
Thank you so much.
We'll now hear from Molly Clark. Molly Clark will be followed by David Snyder.
Hi, my name is Molly Clark. My address is correct on the form.
I'm a resident of Huntsville.
President Trump's immigration policies were designed for mass incarceration and they are working.
As of February 7th, 68,000 people have been detained by ICE.
That's a 70 percent jump from the 39,000 in 2024.
Ten percent of these detainees have been children.
Children held beyond the legal limit of 20 days.
Children given dirty water and moldy food.
Children left with nothing to do but play with rocks.
Some too young to have been toilet trained, left in soiled clothing, waiting for someone to notice, waiting for someone to care.
At least none of them have been reported as dead yet, but it could happen at any moment.
Since the start of 2025, there have been 46 reported deaths in ICE custody.
For comparison, there were 26 between 2021 and 2024.
In 2025 alone, there were 33.
Last year exceeded the death toll of the previous four combined.
Thirty two of these deaths were tied directly to medical neglect.
Nine are suicides.
Five are categorized as other with no transparency.
This year is on track to be worse.
It's early April and at least 13 people have died.
ICE has publicly identified only two of them.
None of these deaths are mysterious.
They follow overcrowding, neglect, and system collapse under rapid expansion.
And this is what indifference looks like.
This indifference is not accidental.
It is foundational to a prison industrial complex that generates billions through the exploitation of those confined.
For such a system to endure, the public must remain either unaware of its consequences or, once aware, be willing to accept them.
Consider yourselves aware now and complicit.
We have built a system that teaches us a simple lie.
That if someone is labeled a criminal, they don't deserve dignity or healthcare or life.
Even people convicted of a crime don't deserve this treatment.
Yet we have people locked up largely because of their color, their skin, and all because of collective indifference.
But the consequences of this collective indifference are not abstract.
The consequences are actual bodies in detention centers.
They are families dying and grieving.
They are people stripped of dignity and children stripped of innocence.
Caring about these deaths is not a radical position, but it seems radical because it's become commonplace to look at these deaths and shrug your shoulders.
Omar El-Aqad said, no atrocity is too great to shrug away now because the muscle of indifference has been sufficiently conditioned.
If you can look at this and not see what it is, that conditioning is working.
You are conditioned by greed, conditioned by political power, conditioned by the media to remain indifferent.
I'm here to reject that indifference.
I'm here to demand that the city take no part in it, that it refuse cooperation with ICE agenda of ethnic cleansing through mass incarceration.
Thank you.
We'll now hear from David Snyder.
And David Snyder will be followed by Liliana Painter.
Hello.
My name is Mick's David Snyder.
I live in Huntsville. My information is written correctly on the sheet.
I put a lot on my plate, so this one will be fast.
I've heard a number of people in my personal life contemplate fascism and Nazism and specifically whether or not our city and city council could be considered fascist.
Definitions of fascism are a system of government marked by centralization of authority under a dictator, a capitalist economy subject to stringent governmental controls,
violent suppression of the opposition, and typically a policy of belligerent nationalism and racism, and or a political philosophy or movement based on advocating for such a system.
As such, Trump is aiming and succeeding at being a populist fascist, and people that support him are supporting fascism.
Definition of Nazism is that it advocates for dictatorship, fervent anti-Semitism, anti-communism, anti-Slavism, anti-Romani scientific racism, anti-Chinese sentiment, white supremacy, Nordicism, social Darwinism, homophobia, ableism, and eugenics.
I believe this concept of white supremacist Nazism extends past these definitions.
I use the term trash acts for transphobic, racist, religious, ableist, sexist, homophobic, and xenophobic.
And I believe people in this maga-culture identity war devaluing certain people's human rights as people that align with Nazism and would have gotten right along with the Nazis in Nazi Germany.
I may lose some people here, but the discrimination and stigmatization of unhoused individuals, sex workers, and criminals are also corroborating indicators of Nazi ideology.
Based on these definitions, I do not view the city of Huntsville and Huntsville City Council as outright fascists.
As we most certainly aren't exhibiting explicit signs of Nazi ideology, I find myself surprised at the amount of times I've actually been proud of our city.
However, there have also been many times I've been deeply ashamed.
This silence in the face of genocide of the Palestinian people, as well as our city's silence in the face of the mass arrests and forced detention of people being targeted explicitly for their race and cultural identity, has been a blatant, atrocious, and shameful devaluing of certain people over others.
Our city's lack of concern over our Palestinian community members that have explicitly asked numerous times for something so basic of humanity as a ceasefire resolution.
My ears burn with shame to think of it.
Huntsville has many aspects that seem to be at a glance to be progressive and equitable.
These values appear to be appeasements in a billion dollar multicultural salad bowl.
We fall short in every field that really matters regarding the values of human rights because we refuse to take head on the reality of racialized classism in this corporate police state that is America.
And because of that, this city ultimately fails at making even basic admittance to the onslaught of disgusting human rights violations this country is committing every single day, much less make any meaningful progress against it.
On that note, our Office of Multicultural Affairs, Emeka and Randy Barber, we need to staff them more and we need to install a...
Thank you, Dane. Thank you.
We will now hear from Liliana Painter. She is our concluding speaker.
Good evening council members.
My name is Liliana Painter.
My address is correct on this sheet.
I'm a Huntsville resident, a working mom and a small business owner.
First, I want to express gratitude for the detailed meeting we had two weeks ago.
The presentations resolutions and initiatives discussed show a clear effort to ensure that residents feel heard.
And that is something I truly value and want to see continued.
At the same time, the length of the meeting highlighted an opportunity to improve consistency, efficiency and transparency and how we address those concerns moving forward.
I also want to acknowledge the Mayor's Office and the many initiatives, organizations and community events that continue to bring Huntsville together. Programs like the Civic Engagement Academy, the Citizens Police Academy are important investments that help our residents better understand how our city operates.
However, we are beginning to see signs of growth that is outpacing capacity across our public systems.
From what is visible, departments like this, like the Multicultural Affairs Office, appear to be carrying a growing scope of work with limited staffing.
Similarly, with public safety programs, there are essential functions that rely heavily on volunteer support.
Because when systems are strained, residents feel it.
Whether that's in access to services, response times or overall quality of life.
So my question is, how are we planning ahead to ensure public service workforce has the capacity to support and structure needed to keep up with that growth?
Planning ahead and investing in capacity also ensures Huntsville remains a place where both residents and small businesses can continue to grow with confidence.
Lastly, how are the boards currently being incorporated into the planning process?
And how are there opportunities to engage them earlier so that residents input is reflected before those decisions are finalized?
As Huntsville grows, we have an opportunity to grow with intention.
And I'll give you back your time. Thank you.
Thank you very much. Mr. Painter is our concluding speaker.
Is there any other business to come before the council?
Seeing none, we are adjourned. Thank you, Mr. Little.